more than 36 million Americans as you
probably already know have filed for
unemployment benefits since the economic
crisis began back in mid-march 36
million and experts say that these job
losses are hitting women particularly
hard especially women of color consumer
investigative correspondent and a Warner
spoke with some women who've lost their
jobs and are trying to figure out what
to do now and a good morning I remember
in the Great Recession it was mostly men
who lost their jobs now we're seeing a
change huh that's for sure Tony and
experts say you know women were making
big job gains leading up to this crisis
now many of those jobs have disappeared
mom Megan Hiles led a life in Missouri
filled with family pets and her work as
a massage therapist until she was
furloughed March 14th I went to school
and all of us changed since the virus
she says the spa she works for reopens
June 1st but she and her 11 year old son
both have asthma plus her child care
provider her stepmom has COPD if
something were to happen in my step mom
is in I go and I work on somebody come
to pick him up and come over there and
give something to her she died I was
terrible the pandemic cost fifteen point
five percent of women their jobs in
April
compared with thirteen percent of men
the reason say experts many women work
in areas hit hard by the crisis in
leisure and hospitality education and
health services and retail these are the
industries the types of jobs that are
hugely dominated by women
Diane Lim is an economist think about
who teaches you no grade school kids who
works at a day care center health care
who typically works in a doctor's office
the impact is greatest for women of
color a National Women's Law Center
analysis finds roughly one in six black
women and one in five Latino women are
now unemployed fatima Goss Braves and
the sentence we have basically wiped out
the job gains that women and
particularly black women had since the
last recession in new jersey simone
bailey now
spends her time making face masks this
mother of two boys lost both her hotel
restaurant jobs temporarily laid off
from one the other eliminated let us
know that Bailey says her state
unemployment check is just under three
hundred dollars per week and the extra
federal money only came for three weeks
I see and everybody else that I worked
with all the other women that I was
working with it's the same thing
Goss grave says without extended
unemployment benefits and childcare many
women will suffer we don't know what the
other side of this is gonna look like
Bailey doesn't know what her future
holds so she just keeps sewing used to
working I feel very displaced so I have
to find other things other ways too
one rather stunning statistic from the
Law Center's report they say between the
end of the Great Recession in June 2009
and February of this year
women had gained 11 point 1 million jobs
in April they say the entirety of those
gains was wiped out Anthony yeah that's
a huge setback ana and as you pointed
out in the piece with the daunting part
is we really don't know what the other
side of this looks like Anna thank you